in the bishop one of the bishop pawns
but never ever but i guess magnus said
yesterday the only thing he's never
going to play is the g-pawn yeah he's
never going to play the grub
onto g4 i'm actually really excited
about this move more than anything else
i just like guess the move it's
incredible it could be anything oh i
wish we'd run a twitter poll on what his
first movie would be
all right well we can ask our audience
do you know they have a few steps i can
find out okay they're going to be off
soon so off yeah
will magnus play something strange i
mean he he doesn't look in that funny
mood right now
look at anish you know he must be
excited as well i think anish would love
to see anything oh
can we see can we see him do h4 now
uh yeah this hurry attack the harry
attack this is one of my favorite
openings uh your chestable course is
simon it is yeah if if white pushes this
pawn to square's fours it's a chess ball
course i did with richard palasa and
again if you're a cheapskate like that
twitter guy earlier uh you can look at
it for free no he's gone for a more
positional approach this is very
sensible yeah this is gorgeous we don't
want to see normal chests do we so
um maybe he's saving it for the
knockouts now magnus
and uh yeah as you mentioned it's very
normal very solid as well
um we see one of i'm trying to remember
the exact name the solid system of the
fiance grunfeld i think that's what
peter svidler called it
in his chestable course and this white
queen coming out defending a pawn in the
center very logical stuff i've always
called this kind of setup that black has
uh
produced um the grunfeldt's love is that
correct or is that just me making that
would that make sense as well yeah it's
basically a
mishmash of the grenfell and the slav
we see that from the top players they do
like to kind of put together ideas from
different open the slav we've seen was a
very good opening in in the tour for for
black correct the white was it for white
it was for white yes
we learned something that if you're
playing on the tour probably not a good
idea to meet the queen's pawn opening by
uh adopting this laughter fans correct
better to do something else than nimzo
and indian i think had a very good
percentage for black
actually black was scoring really well
against one e4 that's why we've seen a
trend towards d4 the english opening the
reti opening lots of others e4
out of fashion at the very very top
level at least in this rapid format
and yeah maybe the slav not scoring so
well for black but if you mix it with
the grunfeld maybe you give it a bit of
extra luck a bit of extra spice and
here i'm surprised to see gary thinking
this bishop move by far the most normal
the most logical and okay magnus already
putting pressure on black center we call
this uh kind of half
the slav in a way because blacks pawns
in the middle of the board on light
squares protect each other but now after
this trade
white has the most central born white
has a bit more space black has given up
a whole bunch of squares that being said
the white queen has lost a bit of time
so i'm expecting anishigiri now to just
castle his king
and uh yeah relatively balanced middle
game ahead maybe yeah i expect the white
queen to get kicked about but it's
actually not a big deal
my experience goes that you know you
know the queen would sometimes even find
itself on very strange locations such as
the b1 square
but it's okay chess is funny like that
yeah i try is this the russian variation
where you bring the queen out i mean i
remember some games bottomneck um had
this a couple times and some very
important uh
competitions normal moves coming up here
both sides developing and it really is
about uh is white's center strong or
could it actually be weak i guess this
this position and i always like
personally having the extra central pawn
um i find it a bit easier to play with
i'm sure ivanka does as well
knowing ivanka's style and but david you
you played a gruntfield so maybe maybe
you actually like being on the black
side of this structure yeah um i do
normally but i'd like to be able to
challenge white's stronghold in the
middle uh as quickly as possible now
black's moved this pawn one square
forward it takes longer to push it again
and really break down white center
i guess black will long term be aiming
for this pawn push or maybe even this
pawn push just to challenge and uh if
you can successfully implement maybe a
pawn trade open the position even more
then black bishop for example might come
to life on this diagonal um long term
black has decent prospects but as you
guys mentioned short term white does
have two central pawns against just one
uh so
short term i think the older i get the
more i prefer white in these types of
positions uh minimal risk one plan for
white for magnus right now would be for
example two okay he drops his queen back
first and i'm expecting black's queen to
come out and maybe offer this trade and
then one idea for white is to move his
rook across in order to support a pawn
push and uh yeah here we go this is the
current position and instead of this
rook move white's bishop comes out very
natural square i don't think we'll see a
trade of queens yet it's kind of a
waiting game there if black trades the
white queen after this uh recapture
white gains a semi-open file and
likewise if uh for example
white trades the black queen then black
gains the semi-open file so it's a bit
of a standoff
but magnus's last move with the bishop
um i'm not aware of it being a main move
i mean like you mentioned the rook
stepping sideways one square to the
porter the e4 push it seems to be much
more logical yeah i think he's maybe
borrowing an idea from the slav itself
um normally in the slav we wouldn't see
this set up with a pawn here and a
bishop here we would normally see the
pawn maybe push forward on the e6 square
and the black bishop located behind it
on the eastern square and there this is
a very very trendy move the white bishop
coming out but it's basically
the exact same position just with this
small difference of the black bishop
placed on a different square so
it's roughly balanced uh i still quite
like white's chances but anushkiri i
mean once he brings the rooks towards
the center maybe to this square maybe to
this square i think he's solid enough
uh for now
so yeah it's uh
an interesting opening choice i'm
slightly disappointed i must say i'm
deflated now that magnus didn't go for
something a bit more spicy a bit more
aggressive prize really because i mean
this you know when he gets the knockout
stages maybe he has to try to really
neutralize the white pieces a lot more
but he hasn't got much to lose by
playing something a little bit wonky uh
in this game um maybe that shows he
really wants to beat a niche and uh
and give him quite a lot of respect as
well but i have to add so in those games
that we've seen magnus play these very
strange opening moves the results have
been quite good for him right he hasn't
lost any of those games no he hasn't two
draws was it i mean f3 was a no did he
win
that was against duda uh in the esports
cup he was winning yeah yeah he was when
and uh he also beat viditz playing 1d3
yeah which was a bit uh unusual let's
say and then with the h4 move that was a
draw
yeah but it was winning but he was
winning there
and there was a very thematic uh rook
and pawn end game
i recommend everyone to go and check it
out uh a good learning point there yeah
here in the studio yesterday we were
struggling with that rook and pawnee
game between carlson and uh wei yi i
mean we we saw the evaluation bar said
it was winning but how and now we i
think we all went back and studied it
afterwards and it's one of the most
unique rook and porn engagements you'll
find out there wow really good kind of
brain training for end games and
calculation
and talking about learning our quiz of
the day is all about asking the question
what is your experience with chesapore
and elvis mikhailovic says
absolutely worth it and we see a trade
of queens
and if as an amateur i've learned quite
a lot in the next in the lot in the six
months awesome courses and great
teachers just a superb tour chess ball
offers oh that's great very very nice
yeah
tweet from elvis mikhailovic and
john hickman
i think i know john so hello john
says that i they have been using
chessable for over five years as soon as
i discovered
discovered it i felt that it was
something special for chess learning and
i've enjoyed seeing it progress from
strength to strength
uh great to hear that john and hopefully
i will play you again in jersey
ah are you playing in jersey
i think he clashes with this doesn't it
yeah i don't know
yeah but uh you know i actually got to
know and chat to john um
because we would have uh some coffee
together in jersey i love jersey by the
way yeah yeah it's one i mean that's one
of the great things about chess and um
how it unites people and you can meet
new friends and you get to go to strange
places interesting places so it really
is i mean a lot of us we know each other
for all our lives and some of my friends
i sort of met when i was about seven
years old and i'm still in contact with
them so it's it's it's lovely all
through chess so it really has that side
to it as well and uh what jersey i know
they will actually have a team for the
olympiad and for the very first time
they will have a women's team fantastic
big deal because jersey is a very small
chess community and to find five women
players
and it's a really recent development i
mean it's huge and i think chesapeal
might be helping you yeah yeah chess
will gonna uh are gonna help the jersey
team towards uh the olympiad and i think
many people are wondering if you guys
will play we have a bunch of moves
though
we do have a bunch of moves the queens
do the queens have left the board so
we're in kind of a middle game slash end
game right now and white does have a bit
of a weird pawn structure
i'm still unsure whose position i'd like
here to be honest white has a bunch of
weak pawns especially on the b file but
white has a lot of space and a lot of
open lines so um we'll go into the plans
maybe a bit deeper in a moment all right
but still very balanced and are you
playing in the olympia david yes
fantastic gonna travel to india and you
anka
yes aha
and simon
no
you might be there i might be there yeah
maybe
yeah i will probably follow you guys
from here yeah we do have a tournament
coming up a major coming up right after
uh that one finishes the olympiad but
i'm really looking forward to follow you
guys what do you think england's chances
are
do you want me to be really optimistic
or do you want me to be very english and
uh play down our channel i think they
have great chances guys
they really do yeah they're a strong
team yeah they do really well they work
really well as a team yeah and uh it's
going to be really exciting it's going
to be david gwain um
not much for vicky adams mickey adams
yeah actually i don't know i'm
announcing the team before i even know
it yeah i don't think it's confirmed yet
but uh the you know the usual suspects
yeah um
cool well i mean we've done very well
the last few team tournaments but
these days england's uh at least the
open team our kind of top players we
don't play as much as we used to
since the pandemic but you've had some
great results in the tournaments you
have played david
that is some great news and you're part
of the team that beat china we mentioned
that the other day which is incredible i
mean beating
china is just phenomenal phenomenal
results so just do that every round
you'd be all right so yeah
they also have lucky jackets which were
not the color that i intended them to be
but anyhow and it makes everyone look
like school boys and it was like oh my
goodness the first time i saw her i was
like oh but you know we paid a lot of
money for them and i was like okay fine
fine fine you know but they are
incredibly lucky yeah nearly every
single time they wear them someone wins
a medal we've got this great picture
from the world team championships in
2019 where we got silver just behind
russia but ahead of china india um and
then
we literally look like a kind of a
lineup of naughty school boys and all of
us have this blue jacket and all of us
have different colour trousers which
don't match the jacket or the shoes
i need to dig up that picture chess and
fashion
do you think i was wondering i mean like
some chess players and i think they've
become more fashionable in the last sort
of 10 20 years but i don't know in
general chess players have never been
that fashionable have they i mean maybe
at the top top but you go to your
weekend competitions and one way i could
always spot a chess player um like let's
say i got off the tube and i wasn't sure
where the venue was i just look for the
person carrying the plastic bag because
it'd always be the chess player would
always be that person with his maybe
shirt tucked outside their jeans and
carrying that plastic bag and he's a
chess player i'll follow him i'll find
the venue but they got more fashionable
yeah especially at the top i like to
think so yeah well we've got you leading
the way david
i'm just following these guys and uh
talking of these guys we have had a few
moves and the evaluation bar is really
shifting towards black's favor and
on the board i think i'm inclined to
agree i still don't think white's out of
it i think magnus has decent chances but
let's jump in to show what has changed
and uh it's all about the queens coming
off first of all but it's all about
these pawns they are doubled they are
isolated they are weak they're
definitely targets but how can black get
at them um we just see the bishop coming
to the center of the board doing a good
job of blockading um and kind of
neutralizing this white bishop on a long
diagonal and magnus just pushing his
pawn forward and it's a weird pawn
structure all of these pawns now all of
white's pawns on dark squares which
means the light squares are weak but uh
also for example later when black
pushers are pawn forward there are easy
plans of the bishop coming and trying to
grab this pawn
i am inclined to choose black here i
don't think white's out of it for
example if he does drop his knight back
if he's able to for example jump in with
his knight to this dream square
just covering all the holes maybe even
jumping into black's camp later but
it's definitely magnus on the defensive
for the next couple of moves at least i
think anish maybe he needs something
even more direct and this pawn push i
just mentioned does allow for example
white to uh yes going back with the
bishop but white allowing now could you
because you did a ridiculous move here
and this won't happen but because they
love their bishops but could you take
the knight
just so you stop that maneuver which
seemed like a really nice maneuver for
the white knight and then go for your
plan here maybe
something along this line because the
pawn you pointed out white's pawn on the
queen side is a real weakness and at
least you can get some pressure against
that guy maybe
simon really like this idea could be
because i i don't think the white slight
square bishop is fantastic because you
don't really have many pawn breaks to
open it up uh with white's pawn
structure so maybe a simple way to just
proceed here yeah and you're right the
only pawn push you can play actually
loosens the position now the black
knight will simply retreat somewhere and
uh this pawn now
uh eternally weak so yeah actually i i
like that um i like that a lot simon the
more i look at it i think that might be
black's safest but also best movie
played it wow wow
i got a positional idea right wow oh he
he mouse slipped on the next movie oh
but this is also very logical no it's
not about sleep yeah i mean i thought
he'd push it one one square but this
also makes sense right but opening the
position is risky when you've given up
the bishop as well so wow i'm less key
and i thought just put your pawns on
light squares you've traded off your
light squad bishop block it up all these
pawns on light squares now actually help
uh to fight against this uh bishop but
instead anish says no he wants to open
things and after we see a trade of pawns
which is a okay guaranteed to happen yes
this pawn is attacked but it can be
easily defended white just lifts up the
rook now and covers all the holes the
problem is these pawns they are
weaknesses but you can't really attack
them anymore if you drop your bishop
back then white can just remove one of
the attackers of the pawns for example
bishop takes knight and okay very very
level position but black here has an
isolated pawn aneesh definitely doesn't
want that
so in the current position instead of
retreating his bishop he's just put his
remaining pawn on light squares all of
white's pawns are in dark squares all of
black's pawns on light squares
maybe that will just balance each other
out um i don't think white's going to
win this one though because white is the
one with the long-term weaknesses and
also anish hasn't lost a single game so
far in this tournament he has won 7 out
of
13 games incredible tournament fernie
she seems to be in top shape i have to
say maybe his best performance on the
tour since last year's magnus cast
invitational which he actually won yeah
anish giri
since then he's struggled a bit maybe
not quite at his best
we're used to seeing him um in
tournaments like vikanza just
steamroller a lot of players
yeah but some you know the last month at
the other esports he really seemed to
struggle and he looked a little bit sad
and dejected
but sometimes this is what you need to
go through you need to have this dip and
then you can recover and place some
great chest yeah and
well the unfortunate thing about this
format though is that you do have
preliminaries and then everything kind
of gets reset and then you have the
quarter finals and the semi-finals so uh
yeah
he will have to maintain his form yeah
not just today but uh tomorrow as well
he gets bragging rights yeah and also
tiebreak advantages absolutely by
finishing top of the table but if the
standings were uh
exactly like they are now he would
actually face aryan hari then in court
finals and that's been a second for him
several times so they would know each
other very well yeah i mean anyone could
beat anyone in this field but it's
always difficult when you play someone
you've worked with i mean that just adds
a bit of
you know psychology that you don't
really want you just want to be able to
focus on the board but i have a question
to you when it comes to seconds and
the people that they're working for so i
understand that the seconds wouldn't be
able to
use the openings that they prepared
together
but what about the reverse
i think it's just bad etiquette i don't
know if it's any contractual obligations
but it's just
do they have to sign a contract when
they're becoming seconds i mean i i
guess there's con you know legal
documents that you know some people do
some people don't because uh you can't
just you know give away all those ideas
can you you know straight away so i
don't know it's strange i don't know
what the deal is you know never never
been asked still waiting my call out
david
if i'm ever good enough for rich enough
to hire a second simon you'll be top of
the list you have to have a lot of dosh
mates a lot of dosh you know for this i
know how expensive your rates are so
all those chess ball courses information
you know so and uh i mean it's
interesting because we did the a podcast
with anish giri we did one with jordan
van frist and they talked about it a
little bit um about stuff like that and
anish did mention that jordan had to
sign a contract um when he was working
with magnus i mean of course we don't
know the terms of those whether secrets
uh are part of it in terms of which
openings they can talk about which
openings they can discuss with others
but um yeah it's at the very top level i
think it's a different game it's a lot
of cloak and dagger
it's like a spy novel
secrecy yeah i remember that game um
where i'm sorry yeah okay the rook is uh
centralized itself i remember that uh
opening idea that goo felt and i can't
remember who it was that he
he uh they concocted this fantastic idea
together
and uh grufeld student maya chibinonzi
was going to play that position and he
didn't want to tell her so he just said
to her keep looking
keep looking
keep looking
and did she find it she did
but is that kind of breaking the
contract yep
as long as nobody finds out that's right
that's one of my favorite books actually
guru phil's book um
i think it's his life and times his
autobiography he was quite a
larger-than-life character so if you if
you're looking for a good chess book uh
ghoulfield's i don't know his
autobiography written by him is is very
interesting
yeah i mean while on the board we have
seen a trade of one set of rooks a bit
of maneuvering nothing really has
changed the pawn structure is still
exactly the same um the trade of rooks
has meant that black occupies the d-file
the open file but no real entry squares
or no effective entry squares into the
white camp white's king meanwhile
centralizing itself i think magnus here
he's getting ready for a scenario where
maybe the remaining set of rooks get
traded off and then white's king is the
quickest to the center uh white's king
might win the race and uh
is it is it possible for the black
knight to jump in
and give itself up
this is maybe what niche is thinking
about a bit of a flashy move the black
knight here sitting not really doing too
much at the moment and iranka wants to
jump it in to attack this bishop and it
looks like the black knight is under
threat but if the white rook moves and
captures this black knight then it loses
the protection of its own bishop and
black's rook can now capture the white
bishop and suddenly the
black rook creeps behind starts grabbing
some pawns this would be very good for
anish but i think the idea after the
knight jumped in which it has done is
that the rook doesn't move instead the
bishop retreats and now the bishop keeps
everything guarded and this has happened
the black knight now leaping back and
it's going to reposition itself
potentially
on this
eternal outpost where it can't get
kicked away not sure what it does there
really but uh it looks nice and pretty
and uh i'm pretty sure we'll see magnus
improve the king there we go and after
the black knight moves then at some
point we might see a trade of the
remaining ropes interesting move there
from a niche playing very quickly moving
uh the pawn by his king two squares
because you have to be very careful you
know moving pawns because you can't move
them backwards so it surprises me a
little bit uh maybe not a problem as
white doesn't have a knight to jump into
those holes created
um but yeah i mean it seems fairly even
still doesn't it this position very even
and it's kind of both sides have created
a barrier um with this pawn push black
not only has created a path in for his
king towards the center uh but he has
locked down on any white pawn pushes
this pawn can't push forward safely now
this square is covered twice um this
pawn can't push safely now
this uh square is covered twice and same
for this pawn so it's very hard for
white to make progress he's dropped his
bishop back to one of my favorite
squares for this bishop um just because
it's nice and safe but it doesn't
actually do anything here the grizzchuck
square the gristrok square yeah why is
it called that i remember watching a
great game i got my you know i was
cheering it was david howe for the white
pieces against grizzchuk
and uh david had a very good win by
playing this similar idea
in the iron man competition it's funny
in that tournament i won three games
with white by putting my bishop on this
square
ah interesting
i think it's just coincidence they
weren't necessarily great moves putting
the bishop here but it keeps the bishop
nice and safe for later and we might be
about to see uh i know whenever ivanka
makes that noise she thinks it's going
to be a draw uh we might be about to see
the white bishop
i have to watch out if i play you what
was it again let's go
we are about to see a result the players
are repeating the moves and
there we go abrupt but nothing to do the
players repeat aha so there's a draw
between the two top players so far